if you had to go to war would you choose
to go during the Middle Ages the
Revolutionary War or in World War One
I'd go to the one that had tanks and
guns yeah because I'm not going to make
it running across a mud strewn
Battlefield what are you talking about I
think in the Revolutionary War you could
have just like hid yeah you can
empoweredly in any of these wars if it's
me now as I am in the middle ages of the
Revolutionary War they're going to be
hunting me like a Golem because I'm the
biggest man they've ever seen and I know
more than 12 words
yeah no they would just be chasing me
with pitchforks so yeah World War one
because you get a gassing if you're
lucky
that's an easy way to go